one with it already this tournament okay
he's played one d4
magnus may be scared of the jabar london
system pushing a pawn
and
smiling
just denying hans the chance to play
this oh wow you know that he would have
done it now he's giving it away and
magnus just tucks into his uh his food
hands frustrated in his attempts to play
his chestable course well
but that is sort of a sign of some
respect for magnus carlsen as well he
knows hans niemann has made a ball
course and uh i think it's coming out
it's coming out tomorrow this course so
miners haven't been able to watch it yet
oh and uh the chessable course we should
mention it would have arisen uh if black
could wow magnus they're playing the
dutch defense but if black had brought
his night out on the first move which
magnus does maybe 90 percent of the time
against one d4 then we would have seen
the job of london system white's knight
on the queen side jumping out the white
bishop the white dark square bishop
jumping out as well but uh yeah maybe
magnus he hadn't had time to study that
opening and maybe he was just too afraid
of the opening
and
yeah hans of course once the course is
released tomorrow
everyone's going to know what his ideas
are so
that would have been the perfect
opportunity meanwhile we've transposed
into the dutch defense as mentioned and
a very rare customer at top level but uh
by the way
the storm the dutch super solid we saw
this actually earlier in the tournament
uh the stonewall dutch by richard
rapport
and uh that one a bit shaky black has no
control over the dark squares in the
center now but as we mentioned in the
last game between these two black is
adopting that strategy of everything on
light squares in the middle of the board
just to survive the opening and this is
an old favorite of magnus's and uh just
going back to opening choices i do have
an interesting question from jmr18
who asks what opening for hans next game
with white is the most promising against
magnus and this is the bit i want to get
to you is there a kryptonite have you
noticed anything in magnus's
a repertoire with the black pieces where
you think he's a little bit vulnerable
um it's hard he's the world champion for
a reason um off the top of my head i
would say it is maybe things like the
drama london system or something that's
maybe not mainstream of course with his
world championship matches uh in the
last few years magnus has studied one e4
extensively
he's worked out what to do in the
martial defense
as as black he's working out what to do
and for example the nimzo indian the
queen's gambit declined he's worked out
his repertoire there but if you can
maybe place sidelines against him uh
against magnus at least you can get a
game you get a very playable position
and that's what the job of london system
would have done so magnus knowing that
uh maybe
not i wouldn't say his kryptonite but
maybe knowing that it would have been
hans's type of position more than his
he's just steered the game in a
different direction and uh
that's sensible from the world champion
i think hans has done everything he can
in this opening to get uh just a solid
position and uh get a playable position
but magnus doing the same
and that's why these two players are so
good they're not sitting targets at the
top level you can't just play the same
opening every single round you have to
mix things up
and yeah that's what they're doing and
han still smiling maybe just still
annoyed that he didn't get that one
opportunity maybe opportunity of a
lifetime to play his own favorite
opening and i just noticed his t-shirt
as well i think that was the joker on
his t-shirt i wonder if that is a sign
he's going to play some tricks today
well it's a good sign to be relaxed and
yeah you spot those opportunities and
you're a little bit more creative if
you're relaxed and not feeling the
strain
and uh i'm really curious about this
type of position because my favorite
thing to do here with the white pieces
is swap off the dark squared bishops and
you just do i just do that just to
lessen black's control over the big
central square that's an outpost on e5
and you really want to go there with a
knight but first i always try and trade
off okay so there's two ways to try and
trade off these bishops uh for example
you can step forward in this one that's
the way i do it i am like right to the
point swap these guys off the other way
uh we should mention is to step forward
with the pawn and then try and trade the
bishops from this angle much more
popular to do that very popular uh
avenue and for example let's just say
the bishops come off the board okay hans
actually adopting a different strategy
but if the bishops had come off the
board white has full access now to this
central square it is an outpost it's if
the white knight jumps in it is
supported by a pawn and this is quite
promising but black will try and fight
against this by just trading as many
pieces as possible and hans has said no
trades black is slightly cramped and in
the game instead of swapping these
bishops now by bringing it out he kicked
back black's bishop instead and uh once
the bishop retreated stepped forward
with his queen and
as i mentioned black is slightly cramped
because these pieces still asleep still
at home this bishop slightly less active
than it was
however white has committed the pawn
structure and uh now there's no pressure
on black's uh structure here these pawns
are relatively flexible now and maybe um
kind of magnus's dream long term is
going to be to break forward in the
center and trade things off open things
up white has committed gained space on
the queen side so maybe black will try
and play on the other flank on the other
side of the board this one is shaping up
just like the last game with all pieces
on the board it's shaping up to be
really tense and it will explode later
in the game one thing i have noticed
with hans's uh openings
and maybe even his style in in general
is he tends to break the rules
and uh here the rules in this particular
pawn formation is to maintain the
pressure as much as you can and the
battle will revolve around the middle
squares but here he's kind of like no
i'm going to expect extend as far as i
can which to many people would be like
way that's to to committal don't do it
so early and here he immediately tries
to
go forward with his qui queenside pawns
and uh magnus is like no so now we're
going to see a kind of battle between
unconventional chess and uh magnus is
going to try to punish him via the
normal means which would probably be to
do with undermining whites far advanced
pawn
at the right time maybe later you can
try and challenge this guy and uh very
important move actually just to explain
from magnus normally you don't want to
touch pawns on the side where you're
weaker so for example actually white has
a space advantage now on this left side
and you can tell space advantages by
this the direction with which your pawns
are pointing white pawns in the center
they're pointing towards this queen side
now so white has the advantage over here
so normally you don't want to touch
pawns but it's just imperative you have
to stop white gaining even more space
so magnus has pushed his rook spawn
forward clamping down now this pawn
cannot be pushed because it would just
be captured and it would actually open
up the black rook so really important
move there from magnus and after white's
knight jump i do expect the pieces to
start coming out this is the problem
child the problem piece in this opening
blocked in by its own pawns here so you
need to get it out for black you need to
start bringing this bishop out at some
point maybe towards the king side in
this direction or you can plonk your
knight in the center of the board at
least you have firm control over this
square's black so let's go back to the
players it's uh shaping up just like the
last game really nicely
for a long battle yeah and uh talking
about long battles long battles always
have
an audience and uh i really want to
share with you some selfies that we have
croatian way says all the way from
croatia a big hello to everyone in the
studio magnus for a win so there you go
magnus supporter
and
microway t says nice analysis by us
thank you and also has a tweet selfie
and
magnus of course jumping in with his
knight in the center
and uh
jmr18 says senza's greetings from
germany and he's rooting for ding
so
definitely keep those selfies keep those
questions and comments coming and you
can always do that via the hashtag
chesschamps on twitter
absolutely
i really do wonder who you guys are
cheering for i mean hans niemann he must
be getting a lot of fans in the us right
now
yeah i remember actually when the
pandemic first struck
i spent a lot of time on twitch watching
the top chess streamers and he was one
of the most popular every time i logged
on he'd have thousands of people
watching him play bullet games blitz
games against nakamura and uh yeah he
was he's very charismatic guy very
confident guy trash talking his
opponents
and yeah he definitely has a big fan
base and anyone who has watched han
streaming knows that he's one of the
quickest thinkers out there as well he
spots three or four options on every
move within seconds and uh
his decision-making especially over the
last year or two has really improved as
well so
okay meanwhile making a quick decision
magnus trying to put pressure in the
center of the board planting a black
knight in the middle putting his bishop
as well eyeing up some white pawns hands
just
reacting instantly and
also he's the type of
type of player who's very much been
inspired by hikaru nakamura he doesn't
want to find the best move every time
hans he's very much playing against the
opponent's psychology and he's just
playing for consistency he wants those
kind of 70 80 percent type best moves
tucking into his snacks meanwhile and
yeah he just wants to get moves quickly
on the board and to confuse his
opponents inspired by magnus i wonder
because i think magnus was eating look
like a taco bowl or something like that
and this looks like a taco burrito the
hans is eating it's mexican night in the
charity cup yeah it's quite funny
actually there aren't too many sports
where you're sat there in the middle of
play and then you just bring out a snack
i mean i guess you could argue the old
style cricket was like that
but they don't do that anymore right you
just spilt something
meet your full hands
i mean i think the position right now
isn't quite as messy as uh
nice one but yeah it's uh yeah they say
fight fire with fire right but you know
fighting tacos with tacos that's maybe
his strategy
meanwhile yep just a quiet bishop move
there from magnus another plan that i
highlighted a few moves ago that black
bishop is stuck behind its own pawn
chain it just wants to zigzag its way
out
uh into the open and han's just eating
he's gonna make sure he doesn't fall
into the same trap that magnus has done
especially last season on the tour uh
where magnus would often make mistakes
or blunders after eating maybe just
losing concentration for a moment yeah
because yeah i guess you would have it
depending on what you ate you know you
might have a sugar rush and then once
that uh spike goes down maybe you kind
of go into this slump and uh it's just
eating now
yeah
chest competition or eating competition
maybe
yeah well uh kevin
winter tells us on twitter that there
are quite a few premier league
footballers that play chess for example
liverpool's trent arnold rhys james and
martin kelly at crystal palace and ben
chitwell yeah yeah
it's true martin kelly i actually played
yeah crystal falls player yeah and i
also heard about yeah trent alexander
arnold that he likes to play chess as
well i think uh i think he had a chess
event with magnus a couple of years ago
aided by one of england's top juniors
shreyas royal so
yeah some
big big names
and we also know that um
money pacquiao all although retired uh
he likes to play chess as well he's a
great chess player yeah you know i would
put him at the category of around about
1900 2000 at least at least so a very
very strong chess player and an
intriguing fact is that after boxing
after boxing match uh apologies um you
have to stay awake for a certain amount
of hours
and so in order to stay awake
he plays chess interesting yeah because
of all the knocks you get exactly wow
cool
all right well we did have a move david
i mean how would you describe this
position right now yeah um i still think
okay hands they're just reacting
really surprised i'm surprised as well i
would just describe this position as
still relatively standard
still feels like the tension the kind of
excitement is yet to come
i'm trying to think of a football
analogy or a boxing analogy it's like i
guess in boxing when the two players are
just sizing each other up they're just
kind of tip-toeing around each other
occasionally throwing a punch out there
and just uh seeing that blocked but
nothing too drastic um no buses parked
no buses parked
bishop you do have a fiancee bishop yeah
the political bishop i'm going to call
it from now on coulsic bishop yeah just
ready to cut in from the wings later on
yeah and uh yeah black's bishop as well
meanwhile actually doing the reverse of
ballistic's favorite bishop is cutting
out to the wings maybe later on the next
on the let's move so
yeah it's just very very tense it's
still all the but it's actually it's
very blocked and when it's very blocked
it's all about where you can hop in with
your knights
at the moment black has the best knight
of all in the center of the board it can
get traded but only at the cost of
improving black's pawn structure so
i slightly prefer black
but
you can make arguments for both sides
white has a big space advantage with his
pawns here and he's starting to kick
back the black knights or kick them to
the sides of the board yeah yeah
you'll never hear
too often these words from me but i
prefer black here actually as well even
though white has the ideal pawn
structure
i love that pawn structure but i think
it's too soon and i don't think white
has enough control and uh
you know the black knight on the edge of
the board looks bad for the minute but
has the potential to jump into another
outpost on the c4 square the uh bishop
the light square bishop is usually a bad
piece that's actually getting ready to
maneuver itself onto a great diagonal
and black has control of the open a line
i don't see what white is doing
okay and uh maybe lacking a plan uh hans
now has retreated his knight and
oh some tactics might be in the air some
real complications white central pawn is
actually hanging as well so we have to
delve into the position here
first move that came to my mind
after seeing a retreat the first thing
you should always think is to look
forward if your opponent steps back you
go forward and uh here there is some
pressure on black's knight in the middle
it's amply defended though by at this
point by this pawn but you could think
maybe even of sacrificing it sometimes
in some scenarios you can capture a pawn
for example here lure out the opponent's
king it's only defended once that pawn
and then suddenly white's whole central
structure drops this falls with check
and when white blocks maybe you can
start thinking of capturing other pawns
as well
this looks very very tempting if magnus
wants to play it a bit safer and uh not
kind of gamble everything on a night
jump on a night sacrifice then maybe he
can start bringing this bishop out
we mentioned this square earlier this is
very nice putting some pressure on the
pawn and the behind it you could even
now bring the bishop to this square
because it actually has a lot of targets
if the pawn disappears out the way you
could throw it forward later then
suddenly the bishop's x-ray vision will
hit the white queen and hit the rook
behind it this looks tempting to me um
maybe the safest option of all however
is one that ivanka mentioned i'm just
trying to get this black knight into the
game so you could even trade off a set
of knights i'm reluctant to do this
but you could maybe trade off a set of
knights and white has to protect this
pawn so maybe you have to take with the
queen or the rook and then at least now
the other knight gets replaced by an
even stronger knight on an outpost in
white's half of the board supported by a
pawn so yeah it feels like the momentum
is all in magnus's favor and uh creating
threats as mentioned and uh also support
for choice lots of options with more
time on the clock i think magnus is very
very happy this is the current position
he'll either play knight takes night or
maybe bring his bishop out and yeah
looking good for black yeah
and uh
on the subject of uh well i'm just
watching those two players eat and play
chess it seems like the two go hand in
hand rather like a seinfeld episode
milan
on on twitter is also with some food but
this time watching jan
jordan ran forest
and cheering for jordan and utopian wool
gatherer is uh
won their company chess tournament go
go utopian wool gatherer well done for
that congratulations great trophy there
so
big big one up and uh shokan is uh
sending us greetings from kazakhstan and
telling us to keep up the good work and
uh please welcome look at this this very
young magnus supporter so we love seeing
and welcome welcoming the next
generation so love that tweet from
shokan and remember if you want to send
us your tweets your questions your
thoughts then you can all do this via
the hashtag chesschamps yeah and it
looks like the support is uh
getting to magnus the bar is liking it
for him right now ivanka said it you did
prefer no you did prefer yeah you like
fur black yeah exactly yeah
and okay as expected knight takes night
i think this was just the most sensible
most kind of easy to calculate option
you only have to look two moves ahead
there's this myth about chess players
seeing 20 moves into the future but
that's very rarely the case normally we
just see two or three moves in the right
direction and then we stop and we
evaluate and that's what magnus has just
done he saw you can take off a set of
knights you can bring your knight in
gain a bit of time against white's queen
and uh yeah then you start to think
again that's what magnus has done quick
move bring the knight to a good square
and now have another pause
and this could be a big round for
comebacks the bar is really liking it
for david navarro with the white pieces
against liam liam is up by one point
after the first game and uh david anton
he lost the first game two young
christophe duda and the bar is liking it
for the spanish chess player in game two
so maybe he is also about to make a
comeback ding he won the first game
against jordan from forest
in that game the bar is slightly to the
middle but they just
about start no they played for a little
while
yeah i think either way
today is going to be a really good day
for every player's fighting chess index
ah i mean just
usually you see it a bit cagey at the
start of every day especially in the
knockouts there's so much at stake you
normally see players maybe take a draw
here or there just play solid here or
there but not these guys we've got eight
of the most uh fighting dynamic players
in world chess yeah i love that
and okay meanwhile magnus just plays a
move
it's funny how we talked about light
square pawn structure ivanka in the last
game in this game for black it's all
about light squares
for white it's all about the dark
squares with his pawns and uh okay
critical moment now i just saw the
evaluation bar shoot up in magnus's
favor maybe that means there's something
direct maybe you can explode open the
center you've got to time it correctly
though maybe you can push a pawn you
know my favorite thing in the world is
that uh that looks quite
dynamic at least yeah pushing a pawn you
want to push this one oh sorry yeah me
and my arrows you want to put it in a
new way
[Laughter]
in a normal way
uh just push the pawn once uh one square
forward
this does require some calculation you
have to work out that for example after
pawn takes here i think you can take
with a knight to hit the white queen and
gain time but you have to be a bit
careful because if you took with the
bishop suddenly you would walk into some
tactics you would see knight takes pawn
sacrificing to break open black's pawn
structure but more importantly looking
for those checks captures and threats
this is a capture and a check hitting
the black king and next move just
winning the black knight so you have to
calculate these things correctly magnus
does it wow okay full chaos on the board
we talked about the pawn structure here
it was perfect light squares light
squares light squares but now
white is uh sorry black is trying to
break the white structure by uh
undermining this chain and he's
undermining the base of the chain this
is really instructive if your opponent
has a pawn chain undermine the pawn at
the back because then the rest will
easily drop off and uh yeah right now as
mentioned if white captures black cannot
take with the bishop that actually loses
but taking with the knight is very
strong because now you hit the white
queen and okay chaos
we talked about it so many times already
today and it's happening again
white is sacrificing a piece hans is not
afraid he sacrificed a piece against
magnus in the last game giving up his
bishop now he's given up a knight and
the whole idea is the one i mentioned
but he switched the order of the trick
and now after the pawn recaptures as it
has done pawn takes and suddenly black
structure is the one broken but black
has an extra knight what is happening
here knight takes pawn will be met by
queen takes with a nasty check and after
a queen trade hans is gonna
because of this check just pick up this
pawn on the left side and suddenly after
black blocks for example
white's pawns are super scary just like
the last game black has an extra night
but white has the pawns and they're
super close to promotion
oh okay hans i think spotting a golden
opportunity here and
let's go back to the players because
this is about to happen on the board
just as i showed
white now down a piece but about to
obtain these fantastic pawns can magnus
stop it can magnus break white's
momentum
before it completely turns in hansa's
favor
clever by hans niemann yeah
i mean i think this was his best chance
things were turning against him and
remember slow strategic games do not
favor him they only favor magnus so he
needs to just take risks sacrifice
pieces
throw stuff at magnus because that's the
only way to beat him
and uh okay a check black
i don't know if you have to trade maybe
you can block this check with a piece
uh yeah i'm trying to be objective about
it because it was such a moment of
excitement that i got a bit of rush of
blood to my head and i'm just trying to
work out okay what is the consequences
if you do
allow
everything so if you do capture and then
and then the bishop does take the pawn
and white has these two amazing past
pawns are they that dangerous
if we like pour some cold water over us
and just kind of go
can they advance
they look really dangerous they look
super dangerous
but okay okay after the queen trade and
magnus is taking that cold decision okay
and he wow he puts his rook in the way
so actually trying to give up his rook
for white's bishop whoa but he's arguing
that it's more important to keep that
remaining black pawn on the left side
it's actually guarded on the seventh
rank by the black rook now so he would
rather give up a rook for a bishop than
let that really important pawn drop and
that is instructed if you're anchor
you're laughing i'm not i know i'm only
laughing because right after making that
cool defensive move
he got he went and got himself a taco
and started like fishing some food i
mean it's so chill i have i've never
seen the likes of it because normally
the players are like okay right i must
go into 100 focus mode you know and
magnus look at him
it's like
ah you're not college you don't care
i guess when you've won the world
championship five times you've earned
the right to just take a chill and
eat some snacks
like i'm seriously impressed by this
kind of just uh very chill nature that
the world champion has i mean
it's a great place to be actually well
but i mean it's a great move that he's
just played actually i love it and and
the hans now thinking for over a minute
so obviously it's not obvious for him to
take that rook it's not clear at all and
also the nature of pins is that actually
this rook is not running away yet so
this rook is actually stuck it's
immobilized because of this pin so white
does have another move you could for
example just take out take a timeout you
could just push a pawn and
next move if you want you can take it
you can take this rook anytime you want
for example black might move the king
out of the way and then no longer is
this rook pinned it can move on the next
turn and then you take it but uh there
we go he didn't actually take this rook
and uh just to explain why we said it's
such a fantastic move this rook move it
purely it's about defending this pawn so
white's bishop cannot take it now if the
white bishop had actually captured this
rook the downside is that after for
example black recaptures suddenly these
pawns are stuck instead of promoting to
new queens like they were they're easily
blockaded for example if white moves a
bishop and black can just fully blockade
these pawns and actually her weaknesses
if anything they are never ever going to
advance again uh so instead hans decided
okay he needs to take a timeout first he
doesn't want to clarify uh this pin he
doesn't want to kind of show magnus
exactly what he wants to do next he
wants to keep the tension he brings his
bishop out instead so now he's hoping
that magnus wastes a move with his king
and only then will he take the rook so
he wants to gain a move in the process
and is it still called a fianchetto
bishop when we're in this part of the
game
um yeah i guess so this bishop is
definitely encouraged this one is kind
of no longer think edited but it could
come back yeah
so i guess if you're on the long
diagonal from a safe square like this
one this is definitely a fiance all
right and we are naming it the pulithic
bishop today he has
a bishop on his football shoes christian
pulisic who played in our play magnus
charity challenge and he has
signed his very own football boots with
this bishop on them and their upper
auction the bid currently it's over a
thousand dollars you guys but this is a
once in a lifetime opportunity to get
some very unique chess
football boots so go into cctv to make
your bid all the money goes to unicef
and magnus he does move his king he does
move his king out the way so now uh
hanza's decision has been vindicated if
white goes and captures this rook now
he's actually gained a whole move in the
process so that's why don't rush that's
my tip for everyone at home don't rush
if you've got a pin force your opponent
to waste a move getting out of it before
committing uh your pieces so
very instructive and hans staying in the
game keeping things balanced now purely
because he's gained a bit of time and uh
because he forced magnus to spend a move
breaking the tension
and uh yeah i mean imagine christian
politics the football boots are just
they're in front of me i keep looking at
them it's uh
it's not fair there's two and the cool
thing is also do you see that they're
actually the same color as sort of our
champions chester color scheme with the
purple and the orange it's a match made
in heaven again cct yeah cct cct
very cool i mean this must be the only
chess football boots in the world
so cctoaction.com and make your bed okay
and meanwhile the tension was eventually
broken white did go and capture that
black rook because it was about to run
away and uh i think that was the last
opportunity to capture it
yes white's light squared bishop was
fantastic but
bishop for a rook in the end you have to
be a bit materialistic there and now
hans needs to be really
timely with his next few decisions
uh i think you can't really allow
black's light squared bishop as we
showed to come and blockade those white
pawns you need to do something a bit
more quickly because if black reasserts
control then we'll see the material
imbalance come into play right now white
has a rook and two pawns that's seven
points for black's bishop and knight
worth only six but the bishop and knight
are going to be fantastic if they find
outposts if they find squares that they
can sit on safely and that's why you
have to create threats before that
happens
and han's now attacking the black knight
in the middle of the board using that
bishop the fiance bishop the politics
bishop and his rook now in the center
that black knight only defended once it
pretty much has to move
or you can defend it with your king but
now hans is just gonna step up with his
rook one square and give a check drive
that king back and do you think
that uh
hans magnus will repeat the position
because it can we can see a scenario
where he drives the king back one row
and then retreats the rook to attack the
knight and just keep that dynamic going
it's possible it's a sharp position
right i'm hoping not ivanka so the black
king forced back and if white steps back
with his rook the dilemma continues does
black move the knight out the way
you have to retreat maybe not to an
ideal square or does black try and
repeat the position
yeah that's a good question and uh the
first question though is not whether
magnus will repeat by bringing his king
back and forth back and forth it's where
the hans is going to go for this
because
is there another option that's the
question white's rook at the bottom of
the board wants to be improved but that
gives black the necessary tempo to bring
his light squared bishop to the dream c6
square and then black has full control
no you can't allow that if you allow
that then it is basically like you
mentioned many times you know it will
just be rich pickings for for black
because they will have control and not
only that they will start targeting
white's weak pawns on the left and uh
remember
black has one extra attacker than white
the bishop knight will be superior to
the uh to the white rook
if black gets another move or two so
psychology-wise ivanka imagine you're in
this position you're playing the world
champion you've got half his time hands
only with three minutes against five
against six sorry
and he doesn't go for the draw he plays
for the win
wow
that is courageous from the teenager i
think i would have taken the draw i
would have just repeated brought the
rook back the black king moves gave him
another check yeah and uh or at least
made magnus contort himself a little bit
because you know magnus might have also
not wanted the draw and might have made
some concessions yeah that i mean really
risky decision now from hans niemann but
that being said he's doing one good
thing and when your opponent has minor
pieces instead of a rook always try to
remove their remaining rook so black's
remaining rook is really important so
black's minor pieces will guard the
diagonals and the knight will jump
around but the rook is needed on the
lateral on the lines
on the files so trading it off makes a
lot of sense from white's part magnus
really doesn't want to trade off rooks
but
can he run away safely the problem is if
black moves away with his rook the white
rook now that has just moved in the
corner can zoom up the board and some
big threats so
um okay i i think it's a brave decision
i'm not saying it's a bad decision by
hans though he's at least asking magnus
some difficult questions to trade or not
to trade what would you do here ivanka
i think i might be forced to trade
because the rook going to the seventh
row really scares me
and
yeah i think probably trade rooks and
then put the bishop on its put the light
squared bishop on its dream location to
define the position and uh
then slowly slowly start driving the
white road back
and uh you see the trade there was fully
expecting
the light squared bishop to move to the
c6 square yep simply no other option for
magnus he had to trade rooks
and uh yeah again that's where chess
players they think strategically i don't
want to do this but i'm forced and
that's why magnus spent just a minute or
two double checking things and he
doesn't go for the move you mentioned
there ivanka the most natural move in
the position was to improve black's
light squared bishop instead he's gone
for a trade of dark square bishops
instead and
hans they're leaning back uh just
surprised by this decision
it makes some sense because now it's
purely a bishop knight against a rook
but then again remember white has two
extra pawns
so this one it's very much in the
balance we're going to find out the
answer which is easier to play with
would you rather have a rook or a couple
of minor pieces
here
bishop and knight
100 times out of a hundred why in this
particular position because yes white
has two extra pawns but take a look at
both of those extra pawns they can't
move they can't move and not only that
white's rook needs to have flexibility
to travel both sides of the board
doesn't have that either so i think the
i think hans is in serious trouble ah
yeah despite the evaluation but yeah
really interesting and uh one idea that
unfortunately for white doesn't work
maybe the reason the huns reacted is
pushing your pawn forward because
unfortunately after king takes rook it
looks like you're about to make a new
queen on this square but the black
knight can actually hop back just in
time to stop the white prawns promoting
and that means you're stuck you have to
retreat as ivanka mentions if you can't
push this pawn forward it's just gonna
get blockaded and the other extra pawn
is this one which is still far far away
from being any trouble at all and uh
yeah talking of blockades this bishop
now sitting on its dream square again
you can't capture it
and push your pawn forward because the
black knight leaps back to the rescue
and guards the promotion square and
actually a big big threat in the
position uh black was just simply
planning now that his bishop is so
strong to drop back with his knight and
win the white pawns once one falls the
rest will fall as well so hans has had
to go on the defensive dropping back his
rook and uh using his rook purely as a
passive piece
right
black's favor yeah i mean look who's
coming king benjamin you know look at
him look at him youthful who wants to
get in on the action and uh now he's
targeting that weak pawn and
that's i'm afraid it's really bad news
for hans because that's not the only
pawn that's going to fall yeah once this
guy drops the pawn next to it will also
fall and yeah that's why it's simply
better to have two pieces rather than
one even if one of them alone is worth
less uh the bishop and knight together
just too strong and the black king
jumping to the rescue as well hans is
doing a good job of complicating things
he's running forward with the white king
but it's not enough and look at this
nasty night check
black is about to win this game because
after king takes pawn this would have
been a decisive night fork let's go back
to the players magnus in full control
once again wow okay so why is the bar
not as excited as you guys i think it's
just the horizon of the computer the
computer sees that white can survive
maybe the next 10 or 20 moves
only giving a plus one advantage for
black but yeah for humans we know that
long-term step-by-step black will slowly
round up this remaining white pawn on
the left side black will slowly start
advancing his pawns and
it's still going to take a long long
time but black is the one in control and
we saw that actually on the player's
body language just a minute ago hans
kind of leaned back and shook his shook
his head because he knows long term he's
losing and
uh yeah there's still
still some fight left though yeah
there's definitely still some fights you
know if
hans can generate some kind of play on
the right side of the board but again he
has to do it in the right way
i mean once again his pawns on the right
side they could be weaknesses as well
because look at them they're restrained
they can't move forward and
yeah they're on light square so
problems
look at this black just indirectly
lining up his bishop against those white
pawns on the right side now as soon as
the black knight leaps out the way those
white pawns i mean they're weak and
white has weaknesses on both sides
that's the problem with rooks and uh a
huge result for young christophe duda
winning also game two against david
anton he must have turned that game
around he is now by two points he only
needs a draw in game three to be ready
for the semi-final
wow it's a drama for dave danton he has
to win the next game
he's really showing his form in this
tournament now yeah it's been it's been
going up and down suddenly he's losing
all his games and then all of a sudden
he's winning he's also been the
recipient of a great amount of luck
and when you have that kind of luck and
i'm primarily thinking of his game
against eric hanson where he was totally
lost and then eric unfortunately found
the only move to trap his queen and uh
yeah when you get that kind of boost you
sometimes feel that
maybe
things are gonna work your way yeah like
the cards kind of will fall into place
and everything will work out beautifully
i i don't know and chess is all about
confidence yeah we've said that time and
time again but it really is true you've
got to have that faith in your
capabilities and we actually did do an
interview with uh duda before the
tournament and he did say that
his biggest strength in chess is that he
always gets lucky
something about young christoph duda
but you make your own luck
what a great chess player okay and
you're still saying david that magnus is
heading for a win in this game it's
looking very likely uh if you look at
neiman's last few moves as well white's
rook is just waiting there's nothing
else to do white's pawns are stuck can't
push white's king has to stop the black
king advancing on either side of the
board so there's this opposition between
the kings right now so white's rook is
just going up down up down and he's
hoping that magnus can't find a winning
plan
the problem for magnus though is you've
got to be a bit careful where you put
the black knight and black bishop you
have to stop the white rook coming up to
the seventh rank for example and
starting to capture some pawns so you
need full control and this is a nice
move now white's rook can actually go up
to the seventh rank but then the black
knight will come back to the center of
the board delivering a fork and uh
there's the threat of this fork this
double attack right now the white king
and white rook are both potentially
under fire from black's knight so
ideally in this type of position you
want your king and rook as far away from
each other as possible just to avoid any
night forks there's also the threat of
black bishop going and capturing some of
these white pawns on the right side it
looks like uh already neiman has
got only maybe one or two moves to even
prolong the game
he needs to avoid dropping his pawns but
also avoid any knight forks
all right well if he loses this game
hans nimon he will have to make a
comeback at some point magnus will be up
by one point and actually in game three
with the win magnus will be ready for
the semi-final
but still looking focused hans niemann
i must admit i'm very surprised
evaluation bar says only 1.7 for black
because it looks completely winning yeah
i'm also very surprised at that
maybe it's just because it can see
resources like you say
on the far away that humans
just can't and also psychologically this
is going to be a very difficult uh
position for hans to defend
because um
i mean you just
he's shaking his head but his position
it feels miserable you know the pawns
are on light squares none of the pawns
can move the rook has got no great
targets to attack and
all he can do is just shuffle the king
and rook backwards and forwards and just
hope that magnus
just makes a mistake basically i think
just while you're talking i was about to
say this move as well this just wins on
the spot i think for magnus because
white's remaining pawns on the right
side the g and h pawns are both going to
drop now there's simply no way to
protect them black's knight and bishop
both look at the same pawn the white g
pawn but more importantly there's a
night fork in the air once more the
black knight wants to hop into the e4
square checking the white king and
picking up the white rook you can't stop
both threats you either have to give up
your rook or give up your pawns
and either way you're not gonna survive
too much longer i think this is just
almost game over
i just don't see a way for hans to even
uh create a trick right now set a trap
you have to just give up your pawns and
uh once you give up even more pawns
that's just it that's just game over
white's rook is just impotent it just
has no way of fighting against the
black knight and bishop
yeah
and it's just a model kind of end game
from magnus
and it was actually something that we
could kind of
see and actually i think most people
could see if you just take it on a
step-by-step basis and all it was was
magnus just slowly improving his forces
rearranging them putting them on the
good square and then i like the way he
moved his knight he kept on threatening
these knight forks
every time that
that hands was trying to get active he
was like no
maybe
you can lose your brick and another
night fork in the air this is a check
and white's pawn now on the left side
is just about to drop yeah magnus
distracted all the white army on the
right side now he's going and moving
changing tact and going off to capture
the white people
and david navarro he has been able to
make a comeback in the match against uh
liam leia liam he won the preliminaries
winning a bunch of games but uh and also
winning the first game in the quarter
final but a comeback by navarro so they
are now tied after two games so that's
gonna be an interesting one and joden
from forest he is fighting to make a
comeback against uh dingle iran
the bar
i think slightly to the middle in that
game so far but uh they're still playing
and here hans niemann is fighting to
survive in this game dev de niranka is
saying it's looking impossible he has
he's at least not resigning and that's
very instructive just never resign
especially in rapid chess you might get
a chance later we've seen magnus mouse
slip in the past we've seen him uh
master apache several times and uh
yep still some little hope while there
are so few uh pawns remaining on the
board if all of black's pawns disappear
it's just gonna be a draw
and uh yeah maybe he's just got some
glimmer of hope to go after the black
pawns later in the game i'm slightly
puzzled by magnus not capturing the pawn
though i mean i honestly thought that he
would do that and
then we would see another big reshuffle
of the bishop on the night and then
slowly the pawn will get escorted to his
destination but here you know
with his king move
he is allowing the rook to get slightly
active yeah he's just trying to keep
maximum control but maybe he didn't need
to
and uh by the white regaining active i
guess you mean this track you have yeah
well white's pawns now drop but at least
the white rook gets maybe to the seventh
rank it manages to remove a couple of
pawns from the board magnus slightly
shook his head there and black is
running out of pawns
i think you need to keep one of them
alive in order to win this game
and uh importantly as well white does
have a central pawn now a past pawn of
his own
and that pawn might start running
black's king now caught on the side of
the board really not helping there
the black king just off in no man's land
actually immobilized right now and now
the bar is starting to listen to you
guys up to 2.4 microscopes and we also
saw the donation bar for unicef it's up
to
84
000 so we have upped our goal to 100 000
we still have a few more days to collect
money for the people in ukraine unicef
is doing life-saving work for them so
please keep donating
all right
magnus again coordinating his pieces
i mean this is just i mean classic end
game technique just control your
opponent's pawns look how white's pawn
wants to start running up the board but
if it moves two squares forward it
simply gets captured
and uh okay han's there just bringing
his rook across
this uh the only one remaining problem
maybe is that black's king is still
unable to get back into the game but
magnus now he actually sneakily offers a
trade white can come and grab this
knight with his rook and we would see
the white rook disappear we would see
the white bish the black bishop and
knight disappear but black has two pawns
and we call them the trousers one on
this side one on this side to like two
legs of a trousers and white's king
can't stop them both white's one pawn in
the middle easy to stop
so uh okay magnus now just putting his
knife back on an outpost and the black
king has an easy path
back into the game this one is uh slow
but sure it's definitely gonna be a win
for black and it will be harry i think
who takes the the honours in this
tournament
not this tournament in this game ah
yeah that black h-pawn if you look at it
as well it promotes on a light square
that's very important the black light
square bishop is going to escort it
forward
later on so hans he's fighting really
well we've got to give him credit we
wrote him off already 20 or so moves ago
but he's still in this game and
he still needs a miracle to survive but
good fighting spirit from the youngster
that will take him far in his career
yeah definitely you have to be resilient
you have to have that grit especially
when the chips are down
and uh well he is fighting giving a few
checks and just trying to make life
awkward for magnus
and uh hans has to move the king
where to where to step it to
yeah
i'm surprised magnus has pushed his king
to the center because i thought you
wanted to escort this h pawn as you
mentioned down the board and actually
he's going to use his bishop to do that
it feels a bit superficial magnus's
piece is a bit loose now the black
bishop no longer fixed on that outpost
that it sat on
but uh yeah it's still
it's not spoiling anything for black at
least no you still have all the time in
the world and this pawn does advance
and here comes harry and also the bishop
interesting love can also support uh the
b porn as well harry and barry the h and
b pawns
[Laughter]
two pawns are better than one and
white's rook and white's king they're
going to be overworked stopping the two
pawns and we should also mention that if
white later on sacrifices his rook for
the two black pawns a bishop and knight
against a king is a win
and uh magnus there's no doubt in the
world he knows how to win that one how
to checkmate the opponent some
grandmasters still struggle with that
one bishop knight vs king
but uh yeah
that's that's breakfast for magnus
that's uh easy stuff so yeah and unlike
the rick and bishop versus rook i mean
this one is make check mating with a
bishop and a knight is pretty simple
actually once you learn three kind of
crucial positions you can
you can definitely check mate with your
eyes closed almost
yeah i think i've seen fabiano caruana
checkmate uh in a online game with
around 12 seconds on his clock
so it's it's not easy for players
sometimes with hours on their clock but
uh if caruana can check mate with 12
seconds bishop and knight vs king then
magnus can do that especially remember
he's getting 10 seconds after every move
and now this h pawn
i mean magnus is being very brave with
it i must admit this h4 not supported by
its pieces anymore but it's still hard
for white to round up uh that pawn it's
still gonna be a nightmare to go and
bring your king across without walking
into any night checks and white's rook
know how it can't go behind the h pawn
because any squares are covered by the
black bishop it's really hard to stop
now this pawn two squares away from
promotion yeah very difficult as well
because that yeah i didn't quite like
this move because the knight can
actually join in the defense of the pawn
the one thing black definitely doesn't
want to do which might blow the win is
push your h pawn one square further now
it looks like you're about to make a new
queen but white's rook will slide behind
you and you can't defend that pawn
anymore so you have to defend that pawn
now see that's what i would have done
instantly
but if we've been saying if you'd had in
the back of your head teamwork makes the
dream work you would have thought who
else could defend the
okay
okay so the knight defended the pawn
and uh now a check this is really sneaky
uh because the black king had to be
careful where it went but at least now
white's rook gets behind this pawn
remember brooks behind past pawns if you
have a passport use your rook to support
it from behind if you are fighting
against the passport put your rook
behind it as well just to stop that pawn
running
but now both of black's pieces are
defending it the black bishop and black
knight
and white's rook now is pretty much
fixed here stuck here eternally uh just
keeping an eye on this platform and just
note this uh night maneuver not only
does he retreat the knight to attack the
rook but also covers some central
squares that the king the white king
could go to and uh yeah i said that rook
was stuck there eternally i thought it
had to be because now it's gone off the
other side uh it no longer keeps an eye
on the black pawn but magnus shaking his
head yeah yeah maybe he's has he messed
this up i think he's messed this up a
little bit i mean why did he put his
bishop on that i mean i expected him to
put the bishop on the c8 squad look at
magnus's face has he just blown it
because oh look at that he can't keep
his black pawn defended anymore the
black bishop is fixed defending the
other pawn the b pawn the black bishop
can't guard both of them and the black
knight temporarily is dominated by
white's king if the black pawn advances
the white rook slides behind and
back to square one he has to win this
game all over again now magnus
he still may be winning but it's going
to be very hard work this h pawn now is
simply going to be picked off by white's
rook coming across and there we go
white's pawn in the middle very sneaky
from magnus this bishop can't be
captured if the white king takes this
bishop then the black knight hops
forward with a knight fork hitting the
king and rook that pawn was poisoned so
now it's bishop and knight and the pawn
against the rook so now it's all about
that b-pawn starting over to push that
one forward yeah
but
now there's not much margin for error if
you lose the b-pawn it's just a simple
draw you have to make sure that b-pawn
costs white the rook you have to win
white's rook for that b-pawn that's the
only way to win now
but is this one so elementary as well
because uh it's it's a king and a rook
that is actually going to start
harassing black's pieces
and
i think it's still winning objectively
but as you mentioned harassment of the
black king is going to be
the key to saving white look at this
white's rook pinning the black knight
white's rook is going to start checking
pinning annoying you
and the one thing you can't do is let
white give up the rook for one of your
pieces and the black pawn
black has to keep both minor pieces on
the board if he wants to win this game
if the knight disappears or the bishop
disappears even if you win the white
rook
and then it might be a draw so
um okay magnus just maneuvering his
knight around
he's really made hard work of this uh i
just think he got a bit
over excited a bit impatient earlier
just pushing his h-born down the board
not using the uh the dreamwork the
teamwork yeah
he didn't really use the black king
yeah and also you know he just did an
outright blunder with his bishop you
know he could he should have protected
all his assets and instead he got really
careless made a quick bishop move and uh
that was it and maybe
that
what he's doing was to blame yeah
tucking in to the food again
maybe he's just feeling he wants a bit
more energy now but
yeah you're right your banker mistakes
have come when magnus is eating
and okay finally black's pieces are well
arranged so there are no checks right
now for white and uh it will be time
soon for that b paul to start marching
down the board
okay hans how is he going to defend this
maybe later he can rely on stale matrix
if the white king
comes down to the first rank
the one annoying thing for hans as well
is that that black b pawn promotes on a
light square
and the light squares will be covered by
black's bishop if it promoted on a dart
square it would be so much more
difficult
to win this game
wow
if it was a corner pawn on the a file it
would be a draw so uh yeah he's lucky
it's a b pawn magnus yeah
yeah it would be a draw if it were an a
pawn because the rook could actually
just sacrifice itself for a night and
then the king would run to the to the
dark squares in the corner and uh
there's no way you can evict a king on
dark squares in the corner hmm well hans
niemann 30 seconds left now game two
between european fan forest and dig
eventually ended in a draw ding is still
up by one point game three between those
two will start in i think like 10
minutes
duda and david anton they are about to
start game three and that's going to be
a must win game for david anton any
other result duda will be ready for
semi-finals and david namara and liam
they are tied winning one game each in
game three between those two will also
start very shortly and he made that move
with few seconds left on the clock
and defending as we've mentioned in the
past is a nightmare when you're low on
time it's better when you're on the
attacking side going for your opponent's
king or playing with an advantage
because then you can just take a timeout
gain a bit of time on the clock by
playing a few quick moves but when
you're defending every move counts one
slip and you lose immediately and that's
the situation hans is in maybe he's
losing anyway but
if you get low on the low on the clock
and make one blunder you have to resign
so
okay look at the black knight trying to
re-route itself
the way black wins this his knight will
cover the dark squares his bishop will
cover the light squares
so the pawn will be supported on dark
squares by the king and knight
once it gets to the light squares it
will be supported by its bishop
so that's the key you've got to make
sure your knight is ready to cover the
dark squares later okay so now it's
covered on the light squares by the
bishop and no matter where the white
king goes the black knight will start to
control the square the dark square it
wants to go to next this pawn okay so
magnus basically wants his pieces on the
light squares yes and that's actually
how to check mate when you have a knight
and bishop together you want them both
on the same colors for example on light
squares because once your knight's on
light squares you can control dark
squares and uh ah see that's a super
helpful trick yeah nice bishop you want
them
yeah on the same color as your bishop
yeah it's useful in middle games
actually openings as well uh just
general strategy we sometimes forget to
look for patterns but knight and bishop
same colour
unless you have a bishop pair because
then your bishops do that or they're
covering
all the hard work
and okay magnus now using his king as
well so black's knight guards its bishop
and now the king is coming and you yeah
you mentioned ivanka time trouble for
hans niemann i mean how difficult is
this to defend with uh 13 seconds on the
clock i think it's nigh on impossible i
i really do think that i mean because
the plan is so easy you know it's just
to escort that pawn to its destination
and as david mentioned you know you just
gotta keep controlling the relevant
squares and here okay you want to
maneuver your knight and bishop so that
it can support the advance of the b pawn
one more square yeah i'm hoping for two
things in the rest of this game one that
we hit move 100 just because that gives
me a bit of personal satisfaction shows
a really long fighting game and the
second thing i'm hoping for is that hans
doesn't resign i'm hoping that he gives
up his rook for the black pawn at some
point because he has to and then magnus
can demonstrate the technique how to
checkmate with knight and bishop yes
against the king because i think
everyone at home that's really
instructive it might only come up once
in your career but uh you need to know
how to checkmate that how many times
does it come in your career
um zero
really i nearly got it against kramnik i
could have won actually it was very
similar to this i could have won his
rook for my remaining pawn but i didn't
see the way and it was a draw but uh i
could have got knight bishop versus king
so close and i think
i've reached it a couple of times but my
opponents didn't even force me to show
that i knew how to do it they just
resigned
so a bit of frustration now i've been
studying it for hours and hours in my
life and not able to show that i know
how to do it oh and the bar was up to
100 for magnus calls so that means the
checkmate is very close four seconds
okay i've reached it twice in my career
and uh the first time i must admit i
didn't know the techniques so to speak
i knew roughly one position no no not
because i hadn't put the effort in and
then i memorized it because i had to
teach it to my students and i had to
break it down in an accessible way so i
found these three positions and then i
was like
second time i got it i could just did it
there's a few things right there's the
box there's the w there's oh yeah
so yes so the first thing is quite cool
you start off with all your pieces in a
row
and uh
and yeah from there yeah now your pieces
can decide which squares to control them
your knight only moves into w sorry yeah
meanwhile it looks like white has just
castled queenside in a way the king and
rook on the squares they would have
castled on what's black's king doing in
the corner it's very confusing but
meanwhile the black pawn giving a check
about to promote and it's a big threat
in the air with the bishop giving a
check to the king and snapping off the
white rook
and there's also a big threat of
magnus just maneuvering his pieces
around to aid the promotion of the pawn
i'm wondering if white can even give up
his rook now for the black pawn
yes he does it okay he does it so we're
going to see the same game yes
he's going to force magnus to show us
how to check mate now and we will later
see that technique of the night on light
squares here we go and the bishop on
light squares as well controlling
everything and
okay it did resign
marathon game not even move 100 but